there are things a president can do that
we just think are the wrong policy and
there are things presidents sometimes do
that make us question the entire
democratic process and I'm punching my
mic already because I'm so fired up
about this that got the president
elected in the first place today is one
of those Donald Trump has suggested
multiple times that we should bomb
hurricanes bomb hurricanes to stop them
it sounds like a satirical news headline
it sounds like a joke but it's the
suggestion not of a random 73 year old
guy that you just saw urinating
underneath the subway platform these are
the words of a 73 year old guy who
happens to be President of the United
States and the White House is not
denying it here's a paraphrased quote
this is the stuff of Horrors I got it I
got it
why don't we nuke them Trump said they
start forming off the coast of Africa as
they're moving across the Atlantic we
drop a bomb inside the eye of the
hurricane and disrupted why can't we do
that per Axios who is reporting on this
asked how the briefer reacted to trump
suggestion the source says that the
briefer said the Trump sir we'll look
into that
there placating Trump this is how it
works behind the scenes Trump says what
about bombing or nuking hurricanes and
they say sir we're going to take a look
into that Trump reiterated the
suggestion that the government can
intervene with bombs against hurricanes
before they make landfall
multiple times and listen Trump seems to
think he knows a lot about nukes right
remember this beauty having nuclear my
uncle was a great professor and
scientist and engineer dr. John Trump at
MIT good good genes very good genes okay
very smart the Wharton School of Finance
very good very smart you know if you're
a conservative Republican if I were a
liberal if like okay if I ran as a
Liberal Democrat they would say I'm one
of the smartest people that were in the
world screw but when you're a
conservative Republican they try do they
do a number that's why I always sort of
went to Wharton
was a good student went there went there
did this built the floor yet I have to
give my like credentials all the time
because we're a little disadvantaged but
you look at the nuclear deal the thing
that really bothers me it would have
been so easy and it's not as important
as these lives are nuclear is so
powerful
my uncle explained that to me many many
years ago the power and that was 35
years ago he would explain the power of
what's going to happen and he was right
who would have thought yeah so that was
all one sentence by the way the briefer
in another case when Donald Trump
suggested bombing hurricanes was
reportedly quote knocked back on his
heels and that it became so quiet in the
room that you could hear a gnat fart in
the meeting according to a source that
spoke to Axios Trump has reportedly
brought this idea up multiple times with
the Department of Homeland Security with
national security officials with a
senior administration official asked
about this the White House is not
denying it they said we don't comment on
private discussions that the President
may or may not have had with his
national security team that's an
admission that this was suggested by
Trump okay in the world of politics if
you were presented with something
completely ridiculous that of course
didn't happen like hey we heard Donald
Trump suggested going out and personally
murdering people in the streets like
Trump wants to go out and shoot some
people is that true that's something
Trump said you would immediately have
multiple officials saying absolutely
ridiculous the reporting is false never
said it absolutely ridiculous
they said something here that's almost
as crazy why don't we bomb hurricanes
and the White House is saying we don't
comment on what the President did or
didn't say and there's another
administration official who's actually
defending the idea saying that quote
Donald Trump's goal is simply to keep
catastrophic hurricanes from hitting the
mainland which is a good goal to have
this is a defense of the idea of bombing
hurricanes that Donald Trump's has
suggested multiple times so let's go
through it Trump's not the only person
to think of this idea okay back during
the Eisenhower era it was considered we
knew a lot less at the time
is it possible that we could use these
new bombs that we made to disrupt
hurricanes 70 years ago however long ago
was scientists agree it just won't work
period the only disagreement that exists
with this story is did Trump suggest
bombing or did Trump suggest nuking the
Hurricanes so bombs non-nuclear weapons
versus nuclear weapons there are reports
of both that's the only disagreement
that really exists here now it's also
kind of interesting that in the
background of this once again it's
always near non-white people that Trump
is thinking of dropping the bombs right
like I get this is probably just the
coincidence but Trump is thinking let's
bomb the Hurricanes where they form near
Africa maybe coincidental but just sort
of notable nonetheless given how this
administration has been run if Trump
were a family member or a friend if you
cared about him if Trump was a personal
contact you would have staged an
intervention by now and you would have
gotten the person some help how did we
elect someone this stupid or unhinged
and then the answer is well because 60
million people thought this was a good
idea and that basically tells you
everything you need to know about the
American electorate this is a crisis the
crisis is Trump but the crisis is also
that there are tens of millions of
people who are going to enthusiastically
vote to re-elect the guy in November of
2020 ultimately this is going to be a
get out the vote election and that
relates to what I want to talk about
next